[Musique]
avec le temps l'association grand raid a
rassemblé autour de son projet des
acteurs locaux publics comme privés et
pour sa 25e édition
la nouveauté est à l'ordre du jour
officiellement les cas c'est une
démarche qui se veut réformiste hinault
mode le garrec et que l'héritage
culturel bien aux hommes de la rue en
stéréo sécurité quotidienne faisons
avancer les choses en première nous
avons atteint une certaine maturité
mais cette maturité décident pas pour
autant un renoncement
ça veut dire que ont rebondi et en
innovant à notre âge à 25 ans eh bien
nous avons un passé les avons également
tout l'avenir et l'avenir en essayer de
décliner au travers des modifications
substantielles porté sur le logo par
exemple et sur la vie vingt-cinq années
d' aventure qui a conduit sept petites
entreprises à innover dans bien des
domaines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toute l'année des centaines de courses
ont lieu dans les sentiers du
département et cette épreuve res le
temps fort avec ses quatre courses et
des milliers de participants
c'est un focus fort important sur ce
patrimoine de la réunion qui a entretenu
par le conseil départemental et par le
biais de l'eau nf et je dirais c'est un
focus très important parce que ça nous
permet de communiquer sur la réunion sur
le tourisme sur aussi le côté économique
une volonté d'innover pour séduire un
public encore plus nombreux ces six
prochains mois la fête du grand raid
mobilisera l'esprit de nombreux
passionnés de la montagne
[Musique]